here is every known Supreme devil in
Black Clover the underworld is ruled by
three Devils including lucifero who uses
gravity magic which allows him to
manipulate gravity in a wide variety of
ways the second ruler is Beelzebub who
uses an overpowered devil version of
spatial magic the third ruler is
asteroth who uses time magic and
although we've never seen him in the
story we have seen time Magic In Action
thanks to Julius then there's magikula
who possesses powerful curse wording
magic lucifugus whose magic is still a
mystery adramelec whose magic is also
still a mystery and ball who possesses
their magic which allows him to
manipulate air and create invisible
barriers finally we have the twins
Lilith and namah who possess Devil Fire
magic and devil ice magic the two of
them can also fuse into an overpowered
demon form that is much stronger than
the two of them separately for more info
about the Supreme devils and every other
devil in Black Clover check out my full
video link in the pinned comment